[Music]
[Laughter]
I actually grew up in it Atlantic City
New Jersey when I finished all my
college degrees and things like well not
College uh High School degrees then I
wanted to go to California and um uh go
to UC Berkeley so and I knew that I
didn't have the 4.0 so I had to go to a
junior college first so I traveled 9
months from the uh coast of
um of New Jersey to
California I just put all my things in
my car and I drove and it took me about
9 months I stayed different
places and on the way I had already had
a kind of
like um thing about martial arts and
Bruce Lee and all that um you know that
was just beginning to happen so when I
did get to to California I had a lot of
Adventures on the way but when I did get
to
California and I decided to settle in
Monteray which is one of the most
beautiful cities in the world actually
so I said oh just go to the junior
college there and see if I can get a 4.0
and then I'd be able to come in and I
did and I was able to to move
um but the first the first semester that
I took at Monterey Peninsula College was
iido I remember Mary heiney was uh their
teaching she's a very famous um iido
person and um I was always kind of
gymnastically oriented I was always
really
athletic um did football did baseball
did everything you know and um so
then uh I started doing iido and I just
fell in love with it I just couldn't
believe how it was I knew immediately it
was the kind of philosophy I wanted to
follow and then I met Stan pranon I was
doing a little bit with a it was like a
woman's group and I was doing that and
then Stan pranon um I heard of him and
then I went to his uh it was like a
garage
and then we started everyone was there
training already and he was very Dynamic
he was a really Dynamic teacher and so I
thought well this is great this is the
kind of thing I want to do I want to do
something with Falls and gymnastically
kind of and um I remember that at even
at a fifth queue I was wanting to like
jump over like four or five people and
see if I could roll on the other side I
was always kind of like that like a
tomboy so I was doing that a lot so he
was using me for UK a lot and then um at
one point I just became Uchi dasi that
was my first Uchi dasi experience yeah
with stand so I think I was there for
like a year maybe a little bit more as
Uchi dasi and going to all the classes
and going to my um college classes also
and then Dan just decided that he wanted
to move up to uh where it was very
coincidental he wanted to move to uh go
to UC Berkeley but for a master's degree
and then he was going to go from there
to Japan so I said well you're my
teacher and um I actually want to go to
UC Berkeley so it might be a little bit
early for my grades but you know I'll go
there and then
um I went to another junior college and
I got my 4.0 and so then I went into UC
Berkeley Stan was already there and then
um he went off to Japan and so but
before that we went into the um Dojo
that is that was um under CTO Sensei so
was already there right yes yes and so
Bruce clickstein who no longer does
Aikido you probably know the background
then he was teaching and um he was you
know a great teacher in a lot of ways
nobody knew and so uh
then what I saw was in the Oakland Dojo
that Bruce actually left to go to uh do
like a twoyear apprenticeship with CTO
Sensei and then a lot of his older
students went with him and Stan was
already there um so I took a break I had
already started at UC Berkeley so I took
a break and I said well just go and see
how it goes so I went there and um I
already decided when I was there that I
probably would end up doing iido very
seriously and that um you know I'm going
to see if this is the teacher for me so
um that was CTO Sensei and within you
know like
months I I saw that he was my teacher so
I said well I'm gonna when I go back
I'll I'll go into Japanese as a um it
was called at that time Oriental
languages with a an emphasis on Korean
or Chinese or Japanese so I said well
I'll do that and um but I ended up
staying in Japan for like a year and
cyto
Sensei you know knew that things were
changing because he had never had a
female um student that
stayed that long or took it
seriously in fact I was like the only
woman there and but he was a really good
teacher and really um between he and his
wife and um the whole family they took
me in as if I was a family member and
then by the time after a year I could
speak pretty well because there was no
one else to speak to so I had to speak
Japanese I went back to UC Berkeley and
I kept training in the Oakland dojo and
Bruce had come back and um cyto Sensei
had already started kind of using me in
demonstrations um and
then I um well the odd thing was that he
was an amazing teacher he didn't quite
know how to teach women he didn't do
that so much so
but he would throw me a lot and I was
fine with it and he knew I was and then
like eama is in the countryside you know
and so the grass was growing and and he
was saying oh I got to I got to make
sure I like um not mow it but cut it cut
it short you know and so I said oh I can
do that and he goes oh no no Jose D
women can't do that so I'm like you just
threw me across the room and yet you
know and so this is an interesting story
because Daniel
Russell was at that time is soo dasi he
had learned Japanese in six months he
was already starting to do like a
political career he ended up Years Years
Later went to the UN went to different
places he he was really good friend of
mine and um he ended up being the uh
director of the um Security Council with
Obama and he is still doing things like
that and so he kind of had the courage
to um say to me look I will teach you
how to you know use the machine and if
you want to do this and you know like
sort of challenge citto Sensei a little
bit then go ahead and I'm right behind
you so he set me up with it and you know
it was later on that I went ah he had
that kind of personality that's what
took him there and um we stayed in touch
a lot and so anyway so I went out there
at 6:00 in the morning and I was going
and going and it's really like a big
area so it took me like 6 hours to you
know cut everything then I saw CTO
Sensei go into the place uh where we eat
and I thought oh it's going to be really
mad at me that I did this without his
permission and this is what made me stay
with him for so long as a student he
came out and he goes P thank you so much
for um doing you know all the fields and
I know I know it was a long it was a it
was a a long work day for you um I made
soapa for you so please come in and have
lunch and I was like oh my God I can't
believe he did that so then after that
he got better and better about that
whole kind of thing and within years he
was having female students he was
understanding how they can work and you
know he was an old-fashioned guy you
know but really an unusual person and he
had you know I think you probably know
he had 23 years as Uchi dasi with
ensei
um and so
anyway that was the start of it and then
I went back and then I helped Bruce host
him so that was like in the
70s and then um you know more and more I
just got more and more serious I
graduated UC Berkeley I went straight
into the Japanese consulate because at
that time I thought well I don't know if
I want to do a full thing like dojo and
all that so the general councel
he he sort of like took me in he brought
me into the economic department and um I
was writing diplomatic letters after a
while I was like you know um reading
like this other guy and I were reading
like 10
newspapers every day just getting the um
the details of how the like Japan and
America were doing trade Wars then there
was the medfly and then there was all
kinds of things happening at that time
so I was there at a good time but I knew
that you know I would look at the
consoles and they didn't look so healthy
and they weren't so happy and I talked
to my boss and I said I think I might
take a year off and see if it's going to
work for me to do iido or not and cyto
Sensi was like you could do this you'd
be like one of the first women that
would have Dojo so um and he was already
using me for kind of a lot of big
demonstrations and for books and videos
and so I took a chance I went in to a
dojo where it had been
Taekwondo but the guy got a sheriff's
eviction so I you know had to just see
if I could bargain with the landlord and
he said well you have a sheriff's
eviction so so you can stay and um I
won't charge you any rent because you're
not going to have lights or water for 6
months and so you just do it you can
build your place and it was already kind
of built up there was walls and carpet
and mirrors so I did a lot I had a lot
of students that helped me build more
things inside the dojo we trained in the
morning so I didn't need lights and then
at night we had sort of
lanterns and um and then before I knew
it 6 months was up and then he only
charged me something like 800 a month
for the for the place and it was a
pretty big place and where is it San
Leandro California where yes and I never
moved I stayed there the landlord that
was I had a um I had a uh the mom of the
landlord that is still there um
she it was like an oldfashioned thing I
would go pay my rent to I would like
visit her at her house and I would pay
her rent and serious it was like this
she she she would say honey I know
you're you know you're young and you're
you're wanting to do a business so I'm
gonna give you a couple of things of
advice now I got you a bag of groceries
because you don't seem like you have
much money and then she would say and
then she would say and I made you lunch
I mean she was just like a mom an
Italian mom and I grew up with an
Italian family so you know it was it was
like that so um so she kept me going and
they didn't raise the rent so much then
I made a shorter trip to
AMA and then when I came back
um she had passed away and before she
passed away she said to her son you take
care of that that young girl and she's
going to be okay but you promise me
you'll do that and he did for all these
years um we just had our 40th
anniversary and I had my 50th year in
iido and um so it was you know like that
and I kept on um
you know just building my Dojo doing
different uh sort of you know like we
made it bigger and we built rooms in the
back so we could have Uchi Dashi and it
ended up we had four rooms and then the
couch and then people stayed on the mat
and stuff so when we have the events
then we have those
um and you know I I have to say like
everything was
blessed I knew that
iido had um a purpose for the world I
knew that I knew that o
Sensei had that in mind and so as I kept
on
going um more and more the philosophy
and the spiritual uality of it became
more important to me even though I kept
going back to iwama and you know and
then I had the privilege of um
training like all the guys would uh
sleep in the um on the mat so because
there were so many of them and sometimes
there were some rooms but the old Dojo
was connected and still is to sensei's
house so CTO Sensei would say okay all
the guys are there you can't stay in
there so I'm going to put you in O
sensei's house and so I slept in his
bedroom you know he had already passed
away sometimes I slept in his wife's
room you know depending on what was
going on and it was such a beautiful
energy in there and I also felt like I
had lots of dreams about o Sensei and
other things and um so I felt
like you know from that time that there
was something I could do for the world I
didn't know exactly what it was now it's
more clear to me and um you know I felt
that even though our style e woman style
it's pretty physical and a lot of
weapons and a lot of things like that
but within that I felt there was the
spirit of ensei and Aikido and that py
ensei also had that Spirit but he just
didn't talk about it so much his son did
his son did his son and I were about the
same age and we sort of grew up together
from the time we were
teenagers very much so it the case for
hero he wasn't as interested but then in
the middle of everything he'd be in the
field we'd been we'd be doing the
weapons and he would just like sometimes
he would just go off and chop wood and
come back and he would take his Joe and
do that thing that o Sensei did just
connecting and then a lot of times he
would just do different things he would
say let's do it let's do iido
blindfolded let's do iido in a way that
um uh we can go from basic to movement
to Advanced
Techniques and he also was told by well
HTO HDO was going to this uranishi
uranishi is like a psychic in the W in
the aama town so UDA was going to her
and just asking her about some things
and she said oh I see that your
father has this old man with a with a
beard sitting next to him all the time
and so Sao so hioo said oh that's uh my
dad's teacher that's all Sensei and then
um a few other things would happen like
that um and then some times when he
would come to
teach um like seminars and then we were
just together then he would say some
things you know Sao Sensei would um but
not as much as HTO HTO would say at that
time his name was htoo and it's hard for
me to say h because I grew up with him
you know and so with he and I we would
you know just talk about things together
and talk about the spirituality one time
he had like a
Japanese um reporter come and ask him
about Cal dhama and then I just stayed
with him and translated the Cal dhama
meanings that was like really easy for
me because we would talk about it all
the
time there was there was so many and
and a lot of times when he came to
California he was just doing technique
after technique and in his later days I
remember we one of the last
demos um it was like the all iaki and
then he looked like ensei and he was
doing all kinds of things with me
and namoto so he would say to us let's
do blindfolded today
let's do this and he even said he goes
you know in in America and in the
foreign
countries you can be really creative and
nobody thinks you're like kind of odd
said but it's hard to do it in Japan but
he said you know I have foreign students
so I can kind of do that and then um you
know he would just experimenting with
different things and I I saw that about
him and so I knew that the D tactic kind
of approach was there too because maybe
somebody comes in and they've never done
aw style so he has to do that and then
someone that's been there for a long
time he starts pushing them to T
musui and so yeah he wasn't just
technique at all and he talked about he
talked about o Sensei being next to him
you know in another dimension he would
talk about you know different things but
one time I was doing kind of tarot cards
and I said to him um so you know do you
want me to do tarot because I did it
with HTO hdle and he was right there
with me you know I actually
helped answer his question about should
I cook and do iido and then the tarot
cards gave him that and um but then CTO
Sensei went uh
at day you know the thing at day and
then it was a joke with HTO h i that
anytime he would go like H at day like
and it'll never happen you know so it's
it's kind of like that but um but he was
he was amazing that way but couldn't
actually see it all the time you know
and and people did see him as like
strict and you know he was very dis
disciplined but he was also like
big-hearted he was amazing that way and
he do hles like that too you know so um
yeah and oakson geez was like the
toughest woman I ever knew but but in a
really good way you know and I would
always say to citto Sensei well why
don't you bring your wife with you he
finally did he finally did so
M we went to First HTO HDO sitto
sensei's house was so glad to uh to see
everyone and um then we went over to see
inagaki Sensei and uh then we walked up
to toosan we saw the ginger and uh it
was like a beautiful day
[Music]